i think we're ready now to tackle some
more or even more complicated examples
so let's draw something crazy here so
let's see let me draw
a chain
and let me
draw it
like
that
and so like we've done in all of the
examples you want to find the longest
chain we could count from here one two
three four five six seven eight or maybe
it's one two three four five six seven
no or maybe it's one two three four five
six seven eight nine
ten that is our longest chain
let me just let me make that in green so
our longest chain here is in green
so this decade this sorry this backbone
has 10 carbons in it the prefix 410 is
dec it is a alkane since it has all
single bonds so we can write decane for
the backbone and then it has a group
right here it has a group right here
and this group consists of one two
carbons attached to the backbone the
prefix for two carbons is f so this is
an ethyl group the yl is because it's a
group attached to the main alkane chain
so we call this ethyl
ethyl decane but we have to specify
where the ethyl group is attached and we
want to give it as low of a number as
possible so we start counting on the
side closest to it so it's one two
three
four
five so this is five
ethyl
decay now let's complicate this a little
bit more
so let me just copy and paste this
copy
and then
paste
so i have pasted it there and let me
complicate this molecule a little bit
more let me add another ethyl group to
it
let me add another ethyl group to it so
let's say it is we have another
ethyl group over there now what is this
going to be well we still the longest
chain is still going to be that thing in
green so it's still going to be a decane
it's still going to be a decade but now
we have two ethyl groups one on the five
carbon one two three four five and then
one on the six carbon
and then one on the six carbon so what
we write here is you you might be
tempted to write 5-ethyl 6-ethyl decane
which really wouldn't be wrong but it
would just be maybe more letters than
you want to write instead you're right
instead you write 5
comma 6
di-ethyl
diethyl
diethyl decane the 5 6 tells us the two
carbons on the main backbone that the
ethyl groups are attached to and the dye
says that we have two ethanes or two
ethyl groups i should say not ethane
groups two ethyl groups one over here
and one
right over here now let's make it even
more let's make it even more complex
let's take our thing and let's make it
even more complex so let's
let's copy it
and let us paste it
edit
paste
just like that
let's paste it let me make it a little
bit lower over here so the exact same
thing we just dealt with but let's add
one more let's add one more group to it
let's say it looks something like this
let's say on that five carbon let's say
on that six carbon right there
i have a group
that looks something like this what is
this going to be called and here we
probably want to break it down a little
bit we still have the backbone so it's
still going to be a decane
it is still going to be a decade
but let's just do it step by step so we
know that this right here this is an
ethyl group it's on the 5 carbon so that
is a 5 ethyl
this is another ethyl group on the 6
carbon so that is a six ethyl
now we have this group over here so how
many carbons are on this group well we
have one two three carbons on it we have
three carbons on it so we might want to
just call it a propyl group but notice
something we are attached to the carbon
and then it later branches off into two
it actually immediately branches off
into two so we could actually call this
either
secropyl so this right here
this right here we could either call it
propyl
or because it it is connected away from
the i guess it's connected directly to
the branch the way a propyl group works
it you could you could connect to it and
it immediately branches because you only
have three carbons so propyl so
just to clarify things it's sec because
we're attached to two carbons right
there but sec propyl isn't what people
normally call it they normally call it
isopropyl
isopropyl
and the the iso root comes from anything
of the form so if i have a group that
looks like
if i have a group that looks like this
this would be isobutyl because we have
one two three four carbons and we are
attached right here so this is where we
would attach to the main backbone if i
have a group that looks like
this
so let's say i have a group that looks
like this
this would be
isopentyl i have one two three four five
carbons i'm attached away from the
branch but if we go one step more closer
so we're attached just like this we're
attached to the original group
this is isopropyl one two three carbons
let me write isopropyl
isobutyl isopentyl notice what the isos
the isos are like y's i guess it's the
best way thinking and you're attached to
the base of the y in this case you're
almost attached to the base of v but
hopefully you get the idea so the common
name for this group would be isopropyl
or if we wanted to use the systematic
naming we could just start at one as
being let me do this in a good color
as the carbon we are attached to and
then we only have two carbons right over
there so if we have two carbons we're
dealing with an ethyl group
we're dealing with an ethyl group and
then you could say that you have a
methyl group attached to the first
carbon so it would be one
methyl
one methyl
ethyl so this could either be called an
isopropyl group or a one methyl ethyl
group and in either case and we put that
in parentheses in either case it's
attached to the six carbon
in either case it's attached to the six
carbon so the prefixes are going to be
on the sixth carbon on our main we have
a one methyl ethyl
methyl ethyl with the methyl is attached
to the first carbon on the methyl chain
on the
the methyl is attached to the first
carbon on the ethyl chain or we could
call this
six
isopropyl isopropyl group attached to
the six carbon
now when we decide how to write it how
do we know you know we're gonna have to
write essentially the ethyl and the and
the isopropyl we're gonna have to write
all of that in front of the decking how
do we decide whether to write the f or
the propyl first well here you just do
it in alphabetical order and actually
these little prefixes in front don't
matter so you compare the p to the e f e
comes first in alphabetical order so
this would be
this would be
5
5
6
diethyl so even though d well d comes
even before before e but you don't even
count that prefix the e is what matters
di
di ethyl and then we could say diethyl 6
6
isopropyl
six isopropyl
isopropyl this is the common name
six
isopropyl decane
isopropyl
decane this would be the common name for
it if we want to use a systematic name
we would replace the six isopropyl with
six one methyl ethyl so let me write
that down so let me just copy this part
so copy
and paste
right there and then i can copy and
paste this right here
copy and paste
so it becomes 5 6 dietyl 6
1 methyl ethyl i know it's very
confusing when you see it but when you
break it down you really could you would
be able to draw this from this structure
and then finally
and then finally
you finish
you finish with a
you finish with a decane
so hopefully these examples don't
confuse you too much in the next few
videos we'll do more and more examples
because i think with the the
nomenclature on the organic chemistry
the more examples you see the better and
this is really core so in the future you
don't get confused when people throw out
something like five six diethyl 6-1
methyl ethyl decane